what has become of this city there used
to be laws justice not anymore
kram is out of control cats are missing
and townspeople are being victimized
video producer dan crowd here standing
in for reviewer and editor Miguel
concepción to tell you about South Park
the fraction Patrol
in this second South Park game published
by Ubisoft the fantasy theme of its
predecessor gives way to the equally
popular subject of superheroes parodying
the current state of comic book to film
over saturation we see today this shift
is complemented by the change in the
combat system which proves cerebrally
satisfying
despite the juvenile sight of your main
character using flatulence to defeat
enemies and when you add town
exploration that awards practical
character benefits the resulting game is
a delightfully fart tinged journey that
delivers satisfying gameplay and
surprising absurdity in equal measure
the fractured but whole story kicks off
with Eric Cartman cooking up a
self-serving scheme the search for a
missing cap so he can use the reward
money to fund a movie franchise for his
troupe of superheroes as she once again
plays the new kid you promptly joined
Cartman's team [ __ ] and friends engaging
in a host of bizarre stories that play
fast and loose with crude humor and
sensitive topics alike specializing in a
delightfully modern and extremely
confusing Asian art form known as yaoi
this is South Park through-and-through
where outrageous and unpredictable plot
developments contrast against the
day-to-day goings-on of seemingly normal
suburban nights the game follows the
franchise blueprint of lampooning pop
culture and society without in-depth
commentary typify by the quote-unquote
difficulty slider where being black is
supposedly the hardest setting and being
white is the easiest it's an opportunity
to present something meaningful
left-half realized as a fly by gag
seemingly more care was put into the
game's more benign comedic touches
starting with the game title itself the
fractured but whole is in a mere excuse
to hide butthole in a game title it's
also a clever take on Captain America's
Civil War relevant since the game's
story involves two rival superhero teams
[ __ ] and friends and the freedom pals
it's a consistent chuckle fest though
genuine laugh-out-loud moments are
spread thin which is forgivable for a
playthrough that can last over 20 hours
your franchises going nowhere face the
truth Eric you guys are kind of
douchebags the fracture butthole employs
tactics style combat prioritizing
strategy driven thoughtfulness / adept
reflexes the modestly sized combat grids
give the false impression that only
rudimentary battle planning is needed
for success in actuality these sometimes
cramped spaces force you to think
carefully on how to efficiently navigate
your characters around the field ideally
to capitalize on your powers it is
superbly balanced combat system the
value smart thinking while also offering
the flexibility of personal preference
when choosing your character's class and
abilities while it's a stimulating
challenge trying to make a great team
it's even harder to come up with a bad
one for every hero that has a potent
attack that can knock back enemies
there's a buddy who can heal and buff
another advantage is the accessibility
of craftable health restoring Mexican
food this can turn the bulk of
encounters into easy victories though
the fractured but whole offers its share
of optional encounters above your
fighting weight as measured by your
squads might level not to mention a
number of challenging boss fights
growing your teams might is inexplicably
tied to practically every bit of
progress you make whether that's
wrapping up a story goal or completing
the myriad of side quests assigned by
the towns folk as you head to any
objective the various unexplored homes
and businesses along the way are well
peppered with crafting items and side
mission collectibles thanks to a number
of quality of life conveniences
exploring seldom feels like a chore
accessible drawers are well marked with
yellow handles backpacks you've sifted
through remain open and when you've
completed various collection missions
you're awarded by the quest to giver
immediately these benefits far outweigh
the fractured but whole slide annoyances
such as not knowing what attacks in
battle result in friendly fire and the
tiny font of your in-game social media
updates South Park is loaded with
environmental puzzles that can elicit
more than a giggle depending on how a
hurdle is overcome the most challenging
obstacles are surrounded by your
legendary fighting abilities and friends
you can call in for an immediate assist
while the stick of truth had its share
of gassy gags this sequel doubles down
on farting as an essential multi-purpose
game mechanic powerful enough to bend
space and time at your whim proving
useful in battle
your turn is now property upon us
fractured but whole succeeds as an
interactive South Park miniseries while
effectively emulating the show's current
style of adult targeted entertainment
and satirize ation of political
correctness it's consistently amusing
and provocative but without the edginess
this series used to be known for both
the games combat and explorative
strengths effectively bridge the many
comical plot developments it's an
accomplishment that this game will
entertain devoted fans or delivering
jokes that won't fly over the heads of
casual viewers
you